[Music]
the time has finally come the big mouth
mercenary is going on a new Mission and
finding his way back into theaters after
several delays and production breaks
part three of the Deadpool franchise is
now closer than ever that's reason
enough to take a more in-depth look at
the current progress of the sequel enjoy
our new
update the exact plot of Deadpool 3
remains a well-kept secret however
previous indications point to a fun plot
for the first time the movie is part of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe this
suggests that the Multiverse could play
a significant role and in particular
provide an explanation for the
appearance of Wolverine Hugh Jackman has
already confirmed that Deadpool and
Wolverine will have a huge battle at the
start of the film with plenty of
Destruction a logical Next Step would be
for the two to involuntarily team up to
take on the villain whoever that ends up
being it is currently safe to assume
that there will be all kinds of
characters in Deadpool 3 some of them
have already been confirmed While others
are still the subject of much
speculation let's start with the two
leading roles first it is beyond doubt
that Ryan Reynolds will return in the
role of Wade Wilson AKA Deadpool the
actor was largely responsible for the
comic book character ever being brought
to the big screen in the first place and
his humor has had a crucial impact on
the character the big hype surrounding
Deadpool 3 began with the announcement
that Hugh Jackman's Wolverine would be
making an unexpected comeback to the big
screen the Australian is now taking on
the role the iconic mutant for the 10th
time although his story was actually
concluded with the 2017 film Logan he is
making a return Thanks to Reynolds in
the past he had insisted that he wanted
to make a film together with Jackman in
an interview Reynolds revealed that he
wanted to revive Wolverine after his
death in Logan in addition we are to be
introduced to a completely new Wolverine
the classic comic book look of the
mutant in his yellow suit has already
left fans excited thanks to the
Multiverse this change is not going to
be an issue at all and the stories of of
the previous Wolverine movies and Logan
in particular will not be ruined which
was very important to Jackman however it
is quite possible that Deadpool 3 really
will be Hugh Jackman's last appearance
as Wolverine the mutant will of course
continue to play an integral role in the
upcoming phases of the MCU but it is
likely to be played by a different
presumably younger actor according to
rumors Kingsman actor Taran ederton is
considered a hot candidate as in the
comic book the two are likely to be very
reluctant to team up Wolverine in
particular can't really stand Deadpool
the two Rivals first clashed in the 2009
film X-Men Origins Wolverine however
this did not go down well with the fans
it was criticized that the then Wade
Wilson had nothing in common with the
comic character Ryan Reynolds who
already played the character there was
also not satisfied with the performance
in 2018 he then addressed the issue in
his very own way in Deadpool 2 namely by
making short work of Deadpool and
shooting his old
version The X force is is also featured
in Deadpool 3 once again the members of
the X-Men spin-off group were introduced
in the second part and brutally
decimated Again Naturally Colossus is
also back the man made of steel has
already broken a few of Deadpool's bones
and is a fan favorite Brianna
hilderbrand and sholi kutsuna returned
as negga Sonic teenage Warhead and her
girlfriend yukoh the contrasting pair
consisting of a badass fighter with
nuclear powers and a rather sweet ninja
companion already made for some laughs
in the previous film the most important
member of the X force and we can
certainly all agree on this is Peter
played by Rob Delaney he is
characterized by a total absence of any
superpowers or special abilities actor
Rob Delany has already signed his
contract for the third part so nothing
stands in the way of a comeback a very
special New Edition awaits us with
dogpool the perhaps ugliest but also
cutest dog ever has already been
properly teased on social media and
should be a fun new member of Wade's
team however there will also be an
absence from the cast of Deadpool 3 zy
Bates revealed in an interview that she
will not be returning to the role of
domino still she shares the fans
excitement for the new
movie at Deadpool side will once again
be his beloved Vanessa of course played
by Marina bararan also a key Ally of his
is cab driver dopinder played by Karen
Sony another fan favorite who should
also make us laugh out loud in Deadpool
3 we can also look forward to further
verbal duels between Deadpool and blind
Al as Leslie Uggams has likewise signed
up for the new film TJ Miller however
will not be returning according to his
own statement a dispute with Ryan
Reynolds was the reason for his
departure from the
franchise in February 2023 deadline
announced the signing of Emma Corin for
the role of the antagonist in Deadpool 3
Corin has already won over audiences as
lady die in Netflix is the crown sadly
it is not yet known exactly what role
corin will be playing according to
rumors the star could take on the role
of Lady Death well lady death
personifies death and has the ability to
manipulate time and real ity in the
comics she also has a special
relationship with Deadpool and Thanos
the latter in particular is hopelessly
in love with her however she finds
Deadpool much more attractive as he is
IM mortal and Lady Death therefore has
no chance of acquiring his soul her
affection for Deadpool could make for
some laughs in the movie as well however
some insiders claim that corin will take
on a very different role namely that of
Cassandra Nova Professor X's near Twin
Sister Nova is a Mamud a parasitic life
form born on the AST plane she possesses
similar telepathic powers to Charles but
differs from her brother in her
particularly strong
malevolence back in November 2022 the
first indications on platform X
suggested that part three could have a
connection to the Disney series Loki at
the time the Charming character Miss
minutes from Loki sent a greeting to
Deadpool to which Ryan Reynolds promptly
responded after this exchange things
remained quiet around the rumor until
March 2023 when it was confirmed that
Owen Wilson would be part of the cast
Wilson previously played the role of
agent Mobius in the Loki series while it
is not completely clear whether Wilson
will also portray this character in
Deadpool 3 the information comes from
Insider Source Jeff Snider who has
proven to be extremely reliable in the
past in Deadpool 3 another character is
making a surprising return that no one
would have expected Jennifer Garner will
be appearing as Electra she first played
the Assassin in the 2003 Daredevil film
in which Ben Affleck played the leading
role despite the fact that the comic
adaptation was not particularly
convincing at the time her solo spin-off
Electra followed 2 years later which
also flopped her unexpected return to
the role after 19 years speaks both for
the typical humor of the Deadpool series
and for a story revolving around the
Multiverse further rumors revolve around
a return of Ben Affleck as Daredevil
Channing Tatum as Gambit and even an
appearance by Superstar Taylor Swift
according to some fans Swift could take
on the role of dazzler a mutant who
already played a small part in Simon
kimber's dark Phoenix where she was
played by hon Sage dazzler is one of
Marvel's most powerful superh heroins
and has the ability to convert any kind
of sound into beams of light she's also
an extremely talented singer and very
skilled in hand-to-hand combat a leaked
Set photo reveals that Sabertooth will
also make an appearance the animal
mutant an enemy of Wolverine has
previously been played by Le shriber and
Tyler M Daphne Keane is likewise rumored
to appear as an adult version of her
character Laura Kenny AKA x23 whether
these characters will actually make an
appearance remains to be seen however a
proper Cameo party would certainly fit
in with the movie
series the R rating is just as essential
for a Deadpool film as a crazy plot the
previous movies in the comic series from
20th Century Fox were characterized by
hard-hitting action and crude humor in
the United States the previous parts
were therefore all given an R rating
after the Takeover of fox by Disney many
fans were worried that part three would
be made at a lower rating after all
Disney is known for wanting to appeal to
as wide an audience as possible fans
were greatly relieved however when
Disney boss Bob Iger and Marvel boss
Kevin fi released a statement both
confirmed that the third installment
would not deviate from the violence and
humor of its predecessors in concrete
terms this even means that Deadpool 3 is
the first MCU film that will not be
pg-rated finally let's take a brief look
behind the scenes of the Blockbuster for
a long time it was uncertain whether
there would even be another sequel under
Disney and whether it would take place
in the MCU in December 2019 Ryan
Reynolds personally announced that a
third Deadpool movie was in the works
with the entire team at Marvel Studios
in October 2020 the active search for
additional screenwriters began which was
concluded with the signing of Wendy
molanu and Lizzy molanu lalan they were
later replaced by Rhett Ree and Paul
werick who are responsible for the
current version of the script with the
ongoing involvement of Ryan Reynolds
Deadpool 3 is directed by Shawn Levy who
has already directed movies such as free
guy the Adam project and nighted the
museum and was also involved in the
Netflix series stranger things alongside
Kevin feige Ryan Reynolds acts as a
producer and is involved in many
processes behind the scenes filming
began on May 22nd 2023 in London and
Pinewood Studios in buckinghamshire
under the working title Title Wave
another filming location was Vancouver
in Canada however the production of
Deadpool 3 really hasn't had it easy in
recent months the writers and actor
strike in Hollywood even led to the MCU
sequel temporarily being dropped
completely from the 2024 release
calendar fortunately the unions were
eventually able to reach an agreement
with the studios filming has resumed and
a new release date has been set Deadpool
3 will finally be released on July 26th
2024 the first teaser trailer will most
likely be released at the Super Bowl on
February
11th Deadpool 3 may be one of the few
promising movies left in the MCU do you
think that the big mouth anti-hero will
be able to impress once again and was
Wolverine return the right decision let
us know in the comments and feel free to
like this video If you enjoyed this
short
[Music]
overview